there are new charges tonight against
the president's former campaign chairman
and a longtime business associate chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has the breaking news on some
more serious trouble for Paul mana Ford
and Rick gates Thank You Brad tonight
the former Trump aids are charged with
more financial crimes in two federal
jurisdictions Washington DC and now a
separate 32 count indictment in Virginia
over bank and tax fraud for allegedly
laundering more than thirty million
dollars source close to the case calling
it classic illegal pile on as dueling
political memos over surveillance abuse
during the 2016 election enter a new
face the House Intelligence Committee is
ranking Democrat Adam Schiff says he
wants their counter memo out this week
and negotiations with the FBI over what
sections will be blacked out or redacted
are nearly complete a White House
spokesman said there will be no holdup
on their end
if national security concerns are
resolved once it meets the FBI's
standards for ensuring that law
enforcement sensitive and sources and
methods are protected we would support
its its release just like the Republican
staff memo released earlier this month a
source close to the process said the
Democrats version will likely require
the President to declassify it the
Republican memo drafted by committee
chairman Devin Nunez team
Alette surveillance abuse by the FBI in
Justice Department during the 2016
election Republican investigators found
that departments knew the Trump dossier
was funded by the DNC and Clinton
campaign but withheld specifics from a
national security court when it applied
and renewed surveillance warrants for
Carter page a trump campaign aide
committee Republicans say the counter
memo is unlikely to directly challenge
the finding committee Democrats say the
Republican account is deeply flawed the
FBI and the DOJ are comprised of very
good people not acting politically and
doing their work on the American
people's behalf so I do want to see that
Democratic refutation because again that
memo will show that a lot of the
allegations that were made in the Nunez
memo were not correct in a separate
development Fox News confirms David J
creamer a former State Department
official and associate of Senator John
McCain has invoked his Fifth Amendment
right not to testify before the House
panel about the dossiers Russian sources
Kramer who was briefed on the dossier by
its author former British spy
Christopher Steele was a critical link
in the dossiers
to the FBI after the 2016 election Fox
News asked why Kramer took the fifth and
whether he helped get the dossier to
BuzzFeed who published it online in
January 2017 there was no comment from
Kramer or his attorney today fret
captain thank you you're welcome